well welcome welcome and you waking
wrong sorry the three days what that
means on the good side yes she's got
real stinky people hey I thought I would
play with my ass play with my ass play
today I thought I would play fast play
fast play mate there's probably a lot of
snow falling on my butthole girl this
wouldn't go don't you spit on my face
all day with that and then waiting mind
somebody men with smelly asshole okay I
thought
[Music]
Hey I would like yeah yeah you got it
she's an earlier you got a gnarly B hole
right now I do I did run your finger
along you crack your ass you don't need
to sing to your hole you know what come
back with shit on your fingers always
good advice and it's not sexual that's
the best part about it what's the best
part about poop plays it's just a bunch
of guys hanging out and latex dog
costumes yeah just exchanging recipes
yeah it's true
swab swapping keto recipes I think we're
both really keyed up for today what I
both are really excited you know I am
energized because I I came back from
fart Nicks and I had so many mommies and
then you know they tell me things like
you're the water Tim you're the
personality janitor and then it inspires
me to come back and just be those things
yeah we'll get into that later but
there's there's more than a controversy
I would say I doubt that no well you can
doubt all you want this is a huge
episode because you had I don't like
blow it it is but yeah you've had quite
a past three days and for this show it's
pretty much what we're all about
so we're going to do a full hour on what
happened to you I think yeah there's a
lot there's a lot to get into yeah you
didn't sound enthusiastic no no III mean
it was very traumatizing very emotional
yeah so it's going to be a lot to to
talk about yeah
we'll process it but that's what the
show is for to process what happened
yeah think of it as your therapy I do I
do this will be good for me it'll be
good for us as a couple of the family
yeah we're good interviewing you three
and you um all right well let's why
don't we do a proper show open and I
never get in on it yeah we proud of each
other yeah here we go
and then ah later
I uh II when I was masturbating when
everyone in my family to see who aroused
me
my god I tried my father my mother my
children my grandparents my cousins my
siblings and the only one who was my
father
yeah well
[Laughter]
[Music]
I mean first of all for this show it's
supposed to be your mom
that arouses you yeah and I mean houses
normative of her to choose her patriarch
well she is hard fucking core is out of
doubt no kidding gadgets he gets in
there she never plays games just what do
you think she can't shock us anymore
yeah and then she drops that knowledge
who is that banana yeah but you know
when you think about it it kind of makes
sense from us from a Freudian
psychoanalysis perspective yeah because
your father is your first your first
love yeah well she you know she breaks
it down I mean this is a something
that's not new to our show I always
loved that the Beethoven is prominently
played behind her it really does offset
any wacky stuff you say if you have like
intelligent things behind you I know
that's how I start doing for my ass
which is always yeah great no she's
really cool I like her yeah she has a
lot of things going there she has a lot
of things going there yeah she has a
like I said she's not she's not new to
our show we've featured her prominently
before you may remember her I've come
all over my face um
he loves this coming so and she wanted
to come strike that's right I forgotten
how did that come straight end because
guys kept wanting to come on her and all
over her right they were horrified if
their own come touched themselves and
and did the strike work did she get away
I don't know I mean I watch CNN a lot
and I know that's kind of you know so
maybe he's covered on Fox or maybe some
BBC or something I don't know right so I
don't know if it was ever covered but I
know that she did make a big thing about
going on the club well I know there's a
writer strike happening does it have
anything to do I think they inverted
uh-oh so maybe they averted the two
things together I'm guessing because we
didn't know how her her strike ended
that's true
let me see if anybody's not it yes I can
I've got it
what were we have here but yeah so she
she was just she's big on on talking you
know in detail about I think oh here we
go
she could have had a career as a muppet
for the sort of thing I think I should
go on strike against come on I'm try
come yeah
the company thinks she'd like on Sesame
Street we were looking up the character
like who does the voices of cookie and
Oscar like I think she'd make a killer
muppet she has a great voice for that
yeah if she gives up think um she should
do that I think we should go on strike
against come Arthur's right where's your
gun yeah this is on my good good Tom I
don't want to share my cookies that's
pretty nice and then they're like you
have you have to sharing a cookies I
don't want to share my cookies that's
pretty good I want to share my come I've
got this cup of coming it's all mine all
the commas in my balls right yeah stick
to Tom for everyone no I'm going on a
come strike yeah so yeah okay that's
really good yeah yeah I can tell you
about a lot of children's programming I
do mmm no Scream screen
Oscars our favorite right Oscar's
awesome scram see man slimey how we
integrate the fact we have a child that
we're into you know we're a family show
correctly Ellie yeah yeah
we discuss things that appeal to adults
that come strikes
just because you become a mom and dad
doesn't mean you have to be lame no he
loves this coming so him like as a
mother I'm offended by that
Oh dad what happened about dads upset
dad doesn't want to hear going on come
strike I'm going under some strike would
you like to join me on my come strikes
and I don't want it to be like they were
pilot like I'm not trying to make fun of
this lady it's just that she covers so
many things
outside of normal everyday coffee talk
conversations she really adds her job
yeah she gets out there so this is like
this is stuff that maybe we should be
talking about but we're not we're Sam
yeah they should put around the view
whoopee
but they don't have the balls you know
does yeah we do
real shell yeah do your incest fantasies
haunt you do you feel guilt or shame
around them maybe you've never allowed
yourself to have them because you think
it you would be a horrible person if you
ever went there so it's all suppressed
yeah
Wow does she have a PhD in
psychoanalysis to I don't know but she's
really this sex Bert right because she
has written books on it
she's definitely experienced a lot of it
yeah incest fantasies are normal okay
I first learned this from Betty Dobson's
book sex for one and when I read her
book in my late forties and she wrote
about incest fantasies I was repulsed
I'll be honest the idea of of
approaching the subject is terrifying
yeah it's not supposed to be like oh
yeah I totally I get it like you're
supposed to feel ouki right it's not a
good time and if those fantasies do
exist I think in mine does a good job of
shelving them pretty decent in other
words like it's not something that's on
the forefront all the time you know but
again I feel like it makes total sense
when you think about it your mother is
your very first sensual and I don't mean
sexual scent like once you you literally
have her kissing her boobs or life in
the morning in the morning in the
beginning of your life so it makes sense
that that's your first sensual
experience no it's really sexual but
sting that makes sense yeah Wow so
fucking deep did then your mother's
probably the first one it's like errata
yeah things you right now yeah and you
kind of go for it Wow but then would you
marry your mom I mean marrying your mom
all other things totally different just
you know it's just like the gays that's
right yeah so then
a couple years later I actually when I
was masturbating went through everyone
in my family to see who aroused me I
tried my father my mother my children my
grandparents my cousins grandparents my
siblings
Nancy helps me with my father do you
think you your granddad is Harshaw clip
for you by the way for me well just
because you know your woman she's a
woman her father maybe while I was
taking it for the grandparents I know
that you you have some free sexy grandad
fantasies don't you I liked that her
approach to it though it was like I want
to start masturbating and then go
through the rolodex like who turns me on
who turns me on
yeah the time.she it's just it's
different it's brave yeah I'm not sure I
need to go there like that like you said
that's kind of one of those things you
can totally repress your whole life and
be fine
like there's something you don't need to
go into no I'm totally cool with no
hopefully we'll explore it today that
was for me that was the only one that
turned me on my Tony rising but my voice
did not or my mother and Daniel II but I
allowed myself I didn't judge my fantasy
I just went with it because it was
arousing to me oh my and I'm like where
does this fantasy teaches nothing
because she's experiment asking will you
ever date your mom Oscar do you ever
have any sexual fantasies about your dad
getting ice cream
and what it shows me and what it does
old you who I will play with mommy
fucking no I say it involves love the
inside my dad come is about having sex
with someone who loves you oh and who
you feel love for is that what that's
about
they could be great yeah that is a good
one is that is that I'm gonna ask my
therapist about that because she's a
Freudian psychoanalysis does that change
it at all for you no well if you don't
know I wasn't paying attention I was
still horrified like I'm still on the
Rouladen yeah I'm not here annecy is
tied to having sex with somebody that
really loves
you like love yeah yeah that's the
maternal the paternal right thing now
can you masturbate to your dad right
right right got you okay oh is that
we're trying to do we're trying to get
me good to into the same mindset oh okay
no it's still not let's keep working no
no no please no then I don't need after
I'm glad I allowed that fantasy because
now it no longer turns me on like it was
just a step on my sexual evolution yeah
because I think all the fantasies teach
us something nothing or we pressing them
just stops the sexual evolution I
believe okay I do but in all seriousness
do you believe that do you believe that
perhaps she is very sexually evolved
absolutely yeah I think anybody that can
go to the dark side therefore sighs I'm
out of it here's the thing I repressed
so much shit like I am a fucking vault
of dark thoughts
I mean it's I'm a comedian I see a
shrink once a week like the darkness is
so deep in me I can't I can't go here
that's why I love shit like this she
goes there and I can make fun of her
right like we're poking at her having a
good laugh yeah but truthfully yeah
she's actually very sexy she's all way
more evolved me yeah and I can't stand
it like I'm so threatened by it
sharzad that's her name thanks dude it's
all love girl you just blew our minds
again yeah the damn that's not possible
by the way very hard to phase us on the
show okay they know very little like
rattles our cages and sometimes things
are just fun to learn oh this would I
showed you loud okay now I like this one
why not Jim's normal robe routine was
after he killed someone and he was go
upstairs and lay down take a nap I mean
it was like a alpha DJ farmer taking a
valium he's just nice and relaxed and
for the next couple of weeks he's nice
and relaxed and he's like a stress
relief and then you could see it build
up in them again but yeah yeah the only
people relaxed him yeah that's a Kevin
weeks part of the Winter Hill Gang he
ran with James Whitey Bulger your hero
no as I was watching this documentary
and by
guards and so they have different
bodyguards different worlds of being
about in other words they have
entertainer bike Justin Beaver's
bodyguard
they had Nelson Mandela one of his
bodyguards so you have like entertainer
you have a head of state and then you
mean a soccer player was a Nelson
Mandela a hockey players right yeah the
great great hockey player he did so much
from the Blue Jays
I forget what table he may believe you
yeah he really paved the way for so many
great hockey planners but then they had
this guy Kevin weeks who I've seen in
other documentaries yeah and so he was a
he was like muscle for whitey bulger
yeah and so also a really neat guy like
whitey bulger yeah welcome positive like
Tony Robbins telling people what to do
yeah he's a real piece of work affecting
the world is love but then he's telling
me stories about all these different
murders they committed and then he tells
this part where he's like and then you
know his usual routine was he would kill
someone and then just go take a nap and
he's like and then he was just cool for
weeks like you can see that he was like
like killing people really relaxed him
yeah that was uh I know that you've been
high on this clip for days you know
because it's so crazy it is yeah it's so
Fran died also yeah I also love that I
play it for you before that that's not a
nice thing where you're like stop
showing me these things before I go to
sleep well yeah I mean we weren't less
showed you something that you told me it
was in your dream the next day you're
like it fucked up my whole dream course
the thing is you and I were having fun
like we were like we're playing we were
lying about getting the dogs just
getting like schoolgirl that's what I
was like I gotta show you this funny
right and then you ruined the moment
you're like oh hold on speaking of which
I was a really funny clip to show you
and then you turn on the show and I was
like dude I'm about to go to sleep yeah
I don't want to hear about murder and
how this guy like likes killing people
and it makes me sleep nice and relaxed
in the next couple of weeks he was nice
and relaxed and he just like a stress
relief and then you could see it build
up and again but yeah
people relaxed him I think watching
documentaries about people kill people
relaxes you
it makes me laugh quite what part of
that like brings you so much joy it's so
crazy that's why you like having your
mind blown before bed as I would it is
it's just so crazy I here's the thing
inappropriate behavior
inappropriate thing said is a huge
mind-blowing laugh escape for me
so like somebody set like the lady
saying kiss my pussy in the bank course
yeah I always make me laugh well we have
a whole show dedicated I know
inappropriate but for some reason
murdering because it's all so like to
kill anybody talked about it this way is
so far removed from how you should talk
about it
yeah so that's why it makes me laugh
like it was somebody saying in in the
way that you like if this guy was scared
or talking to house care he would it
wouldn't register as it's funny the way
that he's talking he's talking about it
like like he's talking about I don't
know like wildlife no I get it I think
the clip is actually very amusing it is
but it's also really disturbing so what
is what I'm not hearing from you is like
yeah that was funny it's really it's
ridiculous yeah but I'm not sensing the
empathetic sort of and how tragic that
he's killing me well because if we go
into if you if you shift it 30 seconds
earlier or they're talking about the
graphic details of the murder I don't
find that funny because they show good
not only neat that's all I need is I
need to find Oakland ok good economy or
a guy to describe his in his final
evidence he's like it really relaxed him
again you can see that actually he
doesn't register that it's absurd right
that's the funnier part is yeah he would
take a nap you know what I think it is
with these murder shows yeah is that you
consume them the way most people consume
comedies or sitcom I don't like watching
comedies right neither do I very seldom
do I enjoy a comedy but you consume them
at such a high rate like it really is
your favorite thing does it upset you
that I don't share your enthusiasm for
murder
I tell you though my really the thing is
I'm completely convinced that everybody
all of us who consume any type of either
books movies TV shows what we all like
our stories that's the universal thing
it's a story there's only like six
stories right so the thing that I like
about crying archetypes and whatnot but
the crime show what I like is I like the
stories involved in a crime show I like
that
somebody does something and then I like
the path of the people hunting that
person down getting the bike I like that
whole story so you like it when the
murderer gets caught does that I do
enjoy a ride with the killer and you're
like I hope he gets away with this no no
but I want I want if it's a good crime
story you want him to almost get away
with it otherwise it's boring what's the
point yeah you're working you hard
enough yeah you want them you want him
to I mean look at all the great great
crime movies or stories it's that you
know he misleads the investigators he
leaves a clue they think they have him
he gets away I mean that's what makes
their stories exciting okay look I'm not
you know yeah I don't say anything just
curious but also I mean I'm thank for
you in my past I don't do any more like
Skippy which is very relaxing yes very
nice take a nap after oh yeah I mean the
idea that somebody can take a nap after
that is in st. Lucia path yeah of course
yeah associate I'm but that's why it's
like it's jarring to hear about it does
it give him any are everybody and if
they did yeah the last thing they'd be
able to do is take a nap right you know
I my stepfather's dead now and my
mother's dead so I can talk about them I
think yeah my stepdad was a sociopath as
well and I know that it gave him a lot
of joy to stab somebody tires right but
not stab people not people no no he
didn't kill people that I know of now it
did give him a thrill to do wacky stuff
like that but it wouldn't put him to
sleep it would just give him a charge he
actually got excited it was it was like
the yeah it was snowflakes it was
happiness for him and my mom both they
loved to conspire and
and you know get get one over on someone
telling to different but I've killed a
lot of people I know there's comebacks
kind of killed a lot of people yeah yeah
I mean I think I want to say that you
know the original count against Bulger
and his crew was like nineteen oh you
know of right that's what I'm saying
yeah that's really putting on that's
banana that guy's a real psycho fuck
yeah I mean I saw Johnny Depp's version
of him in that movie he's really enjoy
scary yeah he does really actor black
mass but not about Shaq's asshole is
about haha black mask
yes well nasty as hell man yeah black
mask does sound like a like a bee hole
that's covered in yeah Brown it's a lot
it's chocolatey shit your dark chocolate
mm-hmm pretty crazy man
yeah well neat so can we get to finally
your weekend how your life is my god it
was a it's a long journey
next dog around dog so if you're
listening in your cubicle guys trying to
put headphones on don't worry this is
not like I want to tell people because
they hear that and they're like oh god
you know some people are like are you
just gonna just tell me he took no what
happened was I got into sick it's a
story the story so don't this is not
just about a fart or something you know
this is this is a real story got some
dignity I did something you're
definitely going to make fun of me for
but I thought I did it and you know
there's always jokes about buying sushi
from wherever I bought sushi from Whole
Foods whole fight I was there picking up
some things I was a single dad you'll be
left town so I did a single dad run
nanny was here watching the boy I run to
the store and I go I got to get things
for breakfast and lunch tomorrow so I
get you know the usual stuff his milk
and is some fruit some eggs this Annette
when I'm there I had worked out I had
worked out like an hour before so I'm
hungry right but I'm thinking about
cooking in the in it's like that split
my cottage yeah go I'm tired I just
won't have something quick what can I
get that's going to satiate me but also
you know kind of healthy so as I'm
walking through Whole Foods has that the
little sushi there's a chef there like
what day of the week is this this is a
Thursday okay so I'm like you know and
yeah it is later in the day so yeah
stuff probably been made for a while
well I know the Anthony Bourdain rule
like you don't want to order sushi on a
Sunday because the fish markets closed
on yeah what day is I think they buy
their location on Monday that's probably
right but I'm you know like that I'll
fucking ah so fucking I go looking
looking I go okay I look at it okay I
get salmon Sammy you're not pronouncing
it right now min sashimi right it's like
six pieces what color was it
no that looked a fine that was totally
fine got the brown spots perfect so I
grab that real white real Brown I grab
some tuna and then I'm like sashimi yeah
and then I go
need something else and then there's
seared albacore Kemp so and that's on
rice I'm like I you know have like a
couple bites with rice a couple that's
how we do sushi though you don't have
too much rice so anyways I grab that
right I run home I put away the
groceries I start I open these three
things yeah I won't down the Salman take
couple bites of Tunis and open that
seared albacore and the first one I take
a bite with rice right yeah when I go
back and I have another piece of like
salmon or whatever and then tuna and
then I go I love member I noticed it
like that rice balls too big so I take a
take it to see albacore off of it and
like I want to have too much rice and as
I take a bite of it like just tastes
fishy which is a no now the known in
sushi yeah it only sir you didn't taste
it sounds silly but like if it smells
like typic like where you go smells like
a fish market like fish or like
steve-o's mouth yeah like your dog's
mouth that's not what you want so I have
like half a bite and I'm like I'm just
not feeling it man you know but I'm not
putting together you know everything yet
I'm just like I just not digging it well
and also you're a bear and Bears just
put everything in their mouth if it's
like a beehive with the bees swarming
and stinging his mouth he doesn't notice
the bee stinging you you put like molten
hot pizza in your mouth right you choose
to you chew through the pain but so but
this is also pretty you know the smells
- I don't eat anymore really I stop yeah
so so I have basically that's good one
and a half pieces of what I just go like
I'm not digging it doesn't know right
tasting so anyways that's all I have
okay I don't know 30 40 minutes later I
shoot a water hose out of my ass see but
I go that's you know that's normal for
you no I just go like that I don't think
of it as oh this is serious I just think
like that didn't settle right I don't
feel sick I just feel like
you know that was bad something was bad
but I don't feel like it's the next
level bad other words yes times you eat
something it doesn't agree with you out
it's out and it passes can I tell you as
in a meta phobe yeah somebody who's a
severe phobia of vomiting yeah what you
did like first of all I won't even eat
whole food sushi if you ever seen me do
it no no because I'm in a met I'm so
terrified of vomiting number two
whenever I choose an item of food that's
out this is going to sound crazy but
this is one of my crazy food phobia
things I always choose the item that's
farthest back put your always put your
hat put it there yeah they put the the
oldest shit in the front yeah so
whenever I choose eggs milk chicken
rotisserie chicken always go for the
back dude those are the freshest that's
the fresh shit the dry shit's in the
front dude I bet you prison I bet you
picked the fucking first one huh no I
don't remember how I picked it but I do
remember the nasty um don't eat that
shitty the next morning I woke up and I
was like oh I don't know how many shits
did you make after just one but it was
water yeah that was a seven yeah okay I
ended up having the full fucking Bristol
stool chart over the next few days but
yeah it was it was just yeah it was
fucking watch and I was like yeah okay
okay I'm sorry - the shit lock and we're
doing an autopsy on it the next morning
I wake up and I have this basically
you've heard I'm sure people talk about
the coffee that has like grass-fed
butter and MCT oil and basically it's a
it's richer but it's it you get like
good fats and it's almost like a meal
replacement also you know and anyways I
have just that for breakfast right after
7:00 diarrhea which well nope yeah but
the seven is fucking I don't know man
like twelve hours earlier and I feel
fine I don't really yeah I don't feel
sick but it you're probably a little
dehydrated a little bit yeah yeah but I
have that and it's a she eights you so
I'm like I'm not I'm not eating other
foods and I don't feel like I need food
right away you know all makes sense now
offer you four so this land I know what
happened I'm with the boy I feel fine he
has breakfast few hours later oh no we
you know I take him to the park
you have some snacks hat yes lunch then
I have an avocado like as a kind of
midday snack then a couple hours after
that nanny comes over right so now it's
like 2:00 in the afternoon so I've been
with them all eight hours already but
you haven't eaten like real tall that's
why I know and that's why you you're
confused about where you got the
poisoning for yeah so I haven't really
so anything else to push out the jams
right so then it's getting like I said
it's around 2:00 and I'm like now
getting hungry but I also don't want it
you know I have like things that I eat
things I don't eat right so right I have
this like a keto like fuel pack right
I eat that just to has like some
calories from fat and then I go work out
but I make note like I never do this but
when I go to the trainer I go I got tell
you like I feel white and I also am very
tired I've been up since 6:00 and it's -
and I haven't stopped so like I said
it's it is eight hours and I've been
going I'm like I'm just really tired I'm
really tired so the Train is like you
know why don't we I've never asked for
that
I say well we like yeah amends me you
need something I knew something was up
when I go and I hesitated to say
something but I want to be like we take
it easy on me today yeah that I go but
you should but you should look at what's
the shame in the game normally how I do
it right I just go I just go I think I
should and she 100% was like oh we'll
just do lower intensity but you know so
you know even through the workout like
it was alright I didn't feel great but I
didn't feel sick I just didn't feel
great and I thought I was just really
tired which I also was and you probably
were you know low on electrolytes yeah
he didn't exactly you dehydrate your
soul further with coffee Danny told I go
I told her I'm dehydrated I didn't eat
right today yeah and I'm tired and I
haven't done I've been with my kid for
eight hours I'm limiting yeah so
speaking of water where's yours right
here I'm actually drinking it I'm now
sure one who's been drinking so
talk I get home and the night before I'd
also when I was at home farts I bought a
steak and I seasoned it and I was like
I'll eat it after I work out right so I
get the grill right at this point I'm
actually hungry but you gotta wait for
your coals to turn so it's like kind of
waiting more to eat which is like
annoying me yeah I finally throw that
thing on like around probably 4:45 I'm
eating by whatever let's say 5 o'clock a
meeting so I eat about half of it and
then I go okay I don't want the other
half yeah that's not like you
you felt full quickly that's as to
nothing is that when you when you're
sick sick you feel fuller
yes stomachs like created you guess and
shit yeah or whatever it's doing is
telling you stop eating fatty yeah
you're about to get sick I know I know
but then the other thing is that I
started to have indigestion and I'm like
I don't feel like I'm you know what is
it what I've indigestion
I like it and then I get to the point
where so now it's like around 7 or
something where I'm like you know what
because I'm pretty much not just like
sugar free but starch and carbs right
like I don't eat bread or pasta or
anything but I'm getting that feeling
where like I have to put some starch in
me
well it might feel when you're sick I
know but I'm saying I only know I'm
there yet oh so I'm like it's I'm trying
too much it diarrhea that wasn't enough
for you know 20 hours earlier once right
that's not a big deal I mean it's gone
well usually one bout of diarrhea and
I'm like I have to have toast I put some
starch in it it doesn't feel like that
at the time it just feels how it goes
and it's fine so yeah now I'm like I got
to eat something in my stomach to feel
normal right so I make it do make a
toast I put some peanut butter on it I
eat it I don't feel great like after we
fuck I still don't feel good I keep
burping
and I have all this indigestion I have a
spot at the store
Oh nanny looks at me and she goes you
look really tired I go saying when she
does that I go I am like I don't want to
go do this show right now but I have to
you know because I still I'm not like
sick sick I just don't feel up to it I
go the store it's really fun shows our
show there was really fun great great
night out craic but as soon as I'm done
I go home and I get home still have
indigestion I have another toast I still
don't feel good after I eat it I go to
bed I have all this weird stomach
feeling going to bed not pain it's just
like anxious weird feeling in my stomach
you know I can't explain it it just
doesn't feel uneasy
it doesn't it just don't feel relaxed I
know what's going on I wake up a few
times throughout the night no problems I
don't go bathroom I just I just don't
feel good yeah in the morning I wake up
and like within 30 minutes the
floodgates are open yeah I'm just going
and I'm with him alone when I'm with a
little worse and I can't take care of
him feed them play with them and her
keep him entertained and I'm going like
two three four five times that's what I
realized like oh I got like something in
me now so I finally I text her cuz
you're gone yeah that goes anyway you
can come sooner because I don't feel
like I can keep doing both she gets back
to me after a while she's like yeah I
get there as soon as I can
and then I just go go I don't know
probably a total of eight or nine times
in an hour and a half or something I'm
so wiped after that that when she gets
to the house I sleep this is like mid to
late morning I sleep four straight hours
right just completely passed out and
then of course I wake up like feel dead
I don't have any energy so I have some
toast after a little while water and
then after a while after that you know
you start to kind of feel like okay I'm
getting better now I mean not to eat
crazy or anything but like you start
eating you know a cracker body bananas
and then the scale changes I started to
have like like a five and then the next
day I'm like oh I have low energy but I
guess I'm better now I eat something
normal and I'm like back to like six hmm
and like it takes another 24 hours to
feel like today I feel like I'm 85%
normal yeah it takes 3 to 4 days
that's what Dara and I got straight up
soon playing - for now the good thing is
you didn't eat a lot of that as an
albacore that was so nice yeah that
kinda raw fish that shit will take a
night eaten if I had four if I was like
who cares and just eating dicks you
would be in the hospital can I tell you
- the panic that you put into me you
texted me Saturday morning as I'm coming
home from fart Nicks and you go I have a
stomach bug and to someone that has a
phobia I should have said to the toys
yeah and to me who has a severe phobia
of vomiting yeah my world starts to
fuckin spin I'm like oh what am I going
to do
can I go to a hotel how do I not get
near him I have to fortify myself like I
fuckin lose my mind no oh I hate it so
much when that what's scare so anyways
and thank God you didn't have a fucking
stomach flu I'd be I swear we haven't
had one
knock on wood yet with it boy it's gonna
it's gonna the table or I'm just going
to check myself into the hotel sorry
see you later no I understand I'm nice
to know that the other day some backlash
some feedback I should say over last
week's personality debate
that wasn't even a debate you know I I
was feeling you coerced people I'm not
saying I didn't feel genuine you know
not at all hey mommy's I'm listening the
podcast you guys are talking about
personalities how friendly or Curt
people are at airports Toronto is known
as the screwface capital of the world
we're not openly aggressive to you but
we never make small talk during a
Caribana
a huge
accessible we get a lot of people from
the you are coming across the border
I've talked to a few of them they all
mentioned the same thing Toronto's as
friendly as a brick to your face I know
I disagree I've had nothing but
wonderful experiences in Toronto this is
Anton from Toronto K so he's talking
about just
personnel and maybe it's your
personality on hey mommies
I'm a little behind in the podcast blah
blah blah I'm certainly something about
my but hope he has I'm team Christina
finally with a better personality yeah I
know I was not paid but I have some loan
debt if you are offering thanks Aubrey I
guess she wants you to pay her okay
Thank You Aubrey let's see I get in the
mail hey mommy's another one here love
you James mommy Tina is the water and
personality of her mommy Tom showboats
but he's stronger but she's stronger in
both categories yeah I agree
thank you all right here's one hey
Hitler's my wife and I were able to
class and made mommy Tina and partners
last night May 4th I have never seen
Tommy buns live or met him in person but
I still feel I am more than qualified to
put an end to the personality channel
water champ debate first off when gene
was on stage if she wasn't saying
something hilarious she had a bottle of
water to her lips and she had a throat
opened fully like a chubby ASU sorority
sisters for me I'm non Yorkie cific
after the show she ran to the front
lobby to show off her shiny personality
to all the adoring fans she took the
time to show a genuine interest in every
person as I approached the mother
goddess herself I got a little nervous
and the feeling can only be described as
how a young preteen German boy probably
felt needing Hitler for the first but
she immediately bent my nerves to rest
yep she was genuine in her thanks for us
coming to the show this email should put
to rest all the arguing over who the
water champ and the personality champ is
I don't want to hear anything more on
these subjects as I have put them to bed
that's Jeremy Sims
Thank You Jeremy Zinser I you know what
thank you
that's it that's that's the debate yeah
you know it's really fun to do shows and
then there's always like one drunk mommy
when you walk out on stage he goes yeah
yeah ah yeah then the people who don't
know that suffer like I'm experiencing a
few more than one just so you know it's
a bit of a thing that Tommy bowling
what's up brother it's Joe Rogan hey
dude I heard you're having some kind of
a contest with Cristina as you guys are
having a competition to see who has the
best personality which was now crazy
when I heard it come out I didn't even
know she had a person I mean she's a
really funny comedian and everything
like that but like I barely even know
when she's talked Oh weird must have a
competition about this obviously you got
a way better personality and don't have
a personality um but you know my advice
to you though is to like humor her
pretend that she has as a person but
she's the mom of your kids right good
point get my brother uh let's get
together and do some guys shit later so
ridiculous anyways yeah you clearly
influenced that voicemail that's kind of
random that Joey would just call like
that yeah kind of random oh you think so
yeah my favorite was hey Mary wins right
hug I mean I've been thinking about this
a lot and I just obviously Christina but
really good friend of mine and being a
woman you know we talk about a lot of
stuff together and very close to her
so you know having said that clear that
and well it's not clear but I also you
know better on Tom a lot and it's a
because I know Christina said well calm
is just personality what like if I were
to say personalities overall never who
this she's just she's very up and down
and I come my experience views and
they're very even keel and
every magic measured your very logical
yep I'm kind of you're very cool headed
yep and you're also really cool yep you
know it's just so cool you're cool to be
around you don't know what's coming
issues what a trainer so big fan um does
have a better personality but I'm just
saying that it's generally but not that
I hang out with you another she's not
gonna hang out with you d another
personality okay bye wow that's one of
your friends Marilyn right it's like a
very good friend of mine very talented
actress yeah very talented comedian yeah
and you know someone who I've always
enjoyed being around huh definitely a
bigger fan of me I didn't even know you
guys hung out when are you hanging
talked to her door I saw her at the
store yeah Thursday night it's
interesting that I mean she came over
I'm like that when we moved in here a
few times but you know wow I'm just
floored at the lever level of trader
ship here yeah we got Shauna my BFF
Marilyn my BFF yes
crazy Joe Joe yeah I mean that's that's
preposterous that he would train out you
spent a decent amount of time with him
oh yeah yeah no yeah gonna do he doesn't
think you're alive Joe made it real
clear he did yes gosh I'm gonna have to
ask about this yeah you'll see him
devastating you still oh well no um no I
mean a lot of people are you know I mean
yeah we're getting emails from whoever
but not whoever the mommies the fans of
this show who listen to us hours hours
hours and unanimously after my shows and
partner
I had lines of people telling me how
much better my personality was and how
much more water I drink
hi Hitler I used to masturbate to
christina pazsitzky when she was on MTV
yeah this is hard to say
I feel like Tom's personality only
propers up so much no I'm saying beyond
the beautiful repaired cleft palate
Christina make low
on the podcast she has a lighter shade
brown I feel like we've seen I could
stay on camber but maybe mute her and
have personality does it on the mic like
Charo Fran Drescher Phyllis Diller
already in Hickey just a suggestion I
feel like that would take your podcast
to the next level spanking Jeff thanks G
yes singular that is so rude Jeff I
don't know this will not even like you
anymore I don't know if you're ready for
this no maybe brace yourself just get
comfortable
is this a celebrity one - it's just like
it's just people weighing in people
people call it my dad I already know he
hates me hahaha is my mommy I actually
thought of myself and my mom back from
the grave to just everyone of nice and
more I get it you don't like yeah yeah
burn I didn't mean to call you let's go
Dave
Sarah burn but I keep kind of
overthinking it Nords 20 years yeah
calling you and I'll tell you the truth
the the second I heard your voice now my
first thought was I'm going to say
freeze on how Christina I called but I
would never want to have a secret
between you and me that didn't include
her um yeah I love Christina I've known
her for a really long time and she's
please yeah she's more than a friend to
me and she's sisters but I feel kind of
compelled to call because I've been
listening to the podcast and I just a
lot well before I kind of thing I just
must say that Christina she's she's like
I don't know when sisters like a common
only child but yes she's bigger than
that to me and she's yeah she's so
generous with me yes um first of all
time gets little gifts that I don't even
expect to get for no reason at all and
chilly she's been there for some very
tough time
for me and been a very very good on
unjust mental or non judgment or unjust
man to me and you can feel like one of
the crazier people she probably knows
but she doesn't make me feel that way
when I'm talking to her and I'm a great
person great friend
I feel really bad saying this because
she's always been so funny and so pretty
she's like I'd say she's my prettiest
friend and she just I mean she's the
first person in my life that I ever just
went up to tread stop I'm sure as matter
cigarette and we became friends and I
was just like a total dork
it wasn't even cool and I was just like
I didn't even see I just saw this
person's going to be my friend so in
college she just walked up to you yeah
that's how I met Sarah burns Shana who
also called into the show who you filled
her head with life uh yeah she walked up
to us in San Francisco and we just
became front lit early just have a
cigarette and we never meet people that
way yeah and you and you and Shana were
together I'm walking together we walking
to pfm the name of the cafeteria back
then and we locked up who see burn she's
wearing a denim overalls this is like
the night I gave him a picture of her
yeah dude that's exactly right of the
day you met her and the thing no no she
wore the load and I saw her and I
remember going all that chicks fucking
cool like she looked all crazy and cool
like we did cuz we're off you know and I
was like this chicks weird - lets go -
look I want to talk to his weird chick
she came at us hey hi what's up dude a
cigarette and then I say we walk to the
cafeteria together and three of us were
BFFs since then and that was 1994 and
that's how long we've been friends yeah
we're crazy
yeah what she likes more she is my
friend and she's like my best friend and
when she she found you I'm so happy for
her and I just felt like
she's going to get it together when
she's going to be happy and Tonga help
could you come in you come in the room
and it's just like just so funny and
you're just like christina is so funny
you guys together are like I can't keep
up with you guys if you see she's really
suffering oh when you're calm and you're
so glad I know you am so glad you okay
Christina yeah so you've got a better
personality and I think we all know this
we all know you I don't want you guys to
fight about it because you guys are so
good together
come here are you Sarah and your child
is so beautiful thank you man this petty
shit has got to stop I'm sorry to
interfere I love you guys and I'll just
burns by the way Oh
traitor I can only guess you know not
after that Sarah is she out she's done
she's dead to me
Sarah Burns was in big little lies
recently yeah
she's lying I Love You Man how to get
away with murder
yeah yeah yeah she machine that went I
know she did that the second thing she
does drug history you know whatever
turns hot wet hot American song yes yes
yes that's her she's just those last
thing I don't know if it's out yet
though yeah Wow well I mean I'm usually
proud of such my both my accomplished
friends Mary Lynn and her but not
anymore
emember we think those friendships and
Joe for that matter oh my god shows like
did she even have a personality I mean
other people just speaking from the
heart
right clearly I mean Sarah's that was
that you know emotional she goes
excruciating I was hard for her to say
the truth yeah the truth yeah it's
really how much did you pay my friends
nothing nothin I just it's just it hurts
[Laughter]
there's a midwest 11 you know mommy you
got the gun on me now John and Kate here
not so far from the road rules haircut I
had not that fun yeah just a little cool
thing on top there in the back yeah
because I a linear that cut back in the
day and it was the exact front but not
that spike would you do that here we go
no no road rules here no I'm not cute
enough what do you mean you know I mean
you got to be 20 to have that cute ass
haircut really not as a 49 mm you got to
be young and cute I remember that when
that show blew up John and Kate I'm
talking about yes not real Stephanie as
somebody with little interest in women's
fashion every time I saw her I'd be like
fuck is up it's so bad yeah she really
she really trademarked that haircut I do
in Midwest her mom yeah and her outfits
were just super Kmart II like super
khaki I understand the courts I mean she
had eight children yeah she got alright
like the hair was inexcusable
inexcusable and also a haircut that's
like stay away from my vagina sake me
Patrick made this but no very thank you
very nice thank you very nice that is a
haircut that does repel penises the only
reason you get that is to be like knock
it off somebody said this is
overwhelming evidence god you're not yes
mommy
that's not all a specter yeah and guess
what there's only one person in this
group now wearing jeans look at this
denim denim denim this is 1990 and
here's you know denim wow this is such a
weird time those late 90s where
beautiful women were really baggy pants
such a waste of eye candy Thank You
Victor and Jonathan's opposed to the
seat photo evidence Tina can't be
amazing she's the only one not wearing
jeans how do you know I'm not wearing
jeans under those cargo what are you
really a gnome wearing denim underwear
you ever thought about that Jesus you
don't even know what the fuck I got wow
that's really something we talked about
our romantic shower this morning
yeah there's big progress from the hobo
well the infamous hobo shower Galloway's
foul gosh that was over a year ago no
yeah well a year ago we lived an old
house in the other house yeah so the huh
boy shower you came in you started
peeing and it smelled like coffee
College a particle just pure coffee yeah
and that's when the dehydration thing
started cause I'm gonna did you even
drink water because it's our tonight
coffee and spread the cheeks yeah clean
that yeah herbed loose nut rockets yeah
I feel like I maybe farted course she
did and then another firm burps and
maybe those really sexy and you know
what's funny is that we haven't showered
together since it's been a minute and
this morning you were in the shower
before me and I thought why not try to
spice things up romantic you know time
nannies here I get in the shower with
you and I start you know grabbing your
cheeks playing with you whatever
playfulness trying to make a nice
romantic married moment and you started
blowing your nose yeah this is I'm
trying to like hey let's be playful
maybe this I was somewhere what I wasn't
you're still sick so I'm not going to
force anything here I was playful but
then you started to blow your nose in
the shower when your hand in the shower
right and then the part that's really
special with you is that your beard
collects all your boogers so it's not
like the boogers end up on the shower
floor they're all in your beard it's not
okay rinse it off no you don't because
you can't see the light bulb is rinsing
until it goes away yeah but you I had to
keep telling you there's still boogers
in your beard there's still boogers in
your beard and then you kept rinsing and
rinse I got I'm gonna throw up
get out of my fucking face I had to kick
you out and then you know how many and
then you made me wash your asshole oh my
god I'm gonna need so I washed your be
whole like I do Ellis yeah and your
beans and stuff depend
love you I consider that super progress
by the way for what for the ultimate
goal of you playing with my be whole
because I got you yeah because I got you
to kind of run your finger along it a
little bit oh my god you guys are so
disgusting you I had to soak up the
crack a little bit you did it very
cursory kind of course I'm not getting
what I wanted you to really get in there
like I do for my son
yeah but for you there's so much hair I
know that I couldn't find the behold if
I wanted because it's covered there's a
real wall there and you're cracked well
I need that that bottle washer we have
yeah I'm kind of kind of on board with
the waxing now because yeah right yeah I
think I know my chair
maybe maybe make an appointment for me
will you as a present sure for my 40th
41st birthday yeah for my birthday my
wife will work and you wax your ads
although it's bad Tom I know it's a lot
of hair I know I didn't realize it's why
I put my hand in there new nails
oh yeah like dude they're so good so
much hair so much hair but thanks again
for blowing your nose in the shower that
was really I didn't piss I didn't fart
and I didn't burp that's big progress
that's true yeah that's true yeah yeah
but you'll notice it's been a year since
we showered together think about next
year what's going to happen I heard a
great oh yeah another one next year
oh man one of the symptoms I had before
I was discovered with Crohn's disease
interesting well let's just say I knew
something didn't feel right down there
you know in the crotchal ii crotchety
console for my area and anyway in mid
pee midstream I hear a very strange
sound no no okay that emanated from
my four penis and the sound I the only
way to describe this and let me just
demonstrate on peeing I'm peeing I'm
peeing I'm peeing everything's foaming
cream all over here I'm like fuck with
that
I have your peel yeah damn I stopped
came for a second you know and uh I
don't know what to do I was like almost
afraid struck King again but now I'm
starting to burn you know cuz if you
stop yourself mid P uncomfortable
imagine that and he wasn't even sure yet
though but yeah
what you doing homie you you're gonna
fall it tell me start letting little
droplets out then I get it to confidence
to lift that stream flow again start the
flow again my son I could get all I mean
I freaked out yeah and uh because this
sound sound like it sound like a fart
sound like a or a fart sound was coming
from my penis that's bananas never even
heard of that
well fart downs come out of vaginas
that's different though because air is
getting pushed into there yeah how do
you fart out of your penis well it's
kind of normal for us so I can't really
write but you understand why that airs
well I know there's how does the air get
into your pee hole that's what we're
exactly what I'm saying this look is so
strange
then I got up early the next morning to
do my morning pee no no and then the
same but good thing happened really that
same my god bitch man I would work out
okay oh I had to tell someone because of
what if it was a major medical problem I
don't know so I went into my mom's
bedroom and
I tried to explain to her that after I
pee that there's the sound that comes
out of my deck boy and she has like what
kind of sounds and I'm like way well it
kind of what kind of sounds like a fart
ma geez I've been will you ever date
your mom and she said well is that
normal I'm like III said I don't know I
Elena I don't know I don't know if it's
normal like it means the sky I didn't
Fox ago penises do to be hear of anyone
farting to the penis terrible mom
there's anyone geez I don't know I don't
have a penis I have a vagina I don't fly
you know what I fire out of my vagina so
she said you know why you know maybe
I'll um maybe I'll call Rick you know
I'll call Ricky's mom Alaska happens -
Rick was one of my friends I'm like know
anyone there course don't tell Scott my
brother don't tell anybody this is some
crazy shit by the way as a kid there's
gotta be nothing worse than confiding in
a parent and they're like yep I'll go
call this other person can't tell them
all about it yeah that is the way I
remember so many cases for but can you
fucking not telling me this
my mother did that to me constantly yes
the point where I stopped telling her
things when I was I was yeah of course I
kept so many secrets because she would
constantly back stab tell everybody L my
stepdad tell my dad shit that I don't
want people to know it's a really bad
thing to do as a parent I know it's
really fucked up I was really annoyed by
that as I have a lot of empathy for this
guy not cool I just multi-party
I was wondering got you you want your
meaningful wrapping my god you what
sorry no we want you to be part of your
asshole
good play next thing I know he comes
running I don't know Todd
dude you're farting through your deck
Barney threw your dick Christ this is my
life yeah so it's Crohn's disease huh I
guess I still don't know how that
happens pre-diagnosis he was farting
through his dick how does that happen I
have no clue
sounds bananas the air has to find its
way into what your bladder I don't know
I mean a pocket of air has to there it
goes in or there's air in your bladder
that needs to come out that's what I'm
saying
right so either the air gets in or out
what the airs not getting in into your
dick hole no that's not happening
so there somehow is seeping into his
bladder
oh hey terrifying that's yeah well
thanks for playing that yeah no problem
can we talk about hole let's just write
about so for the we haven't had a clocks
on both of our bedside tables now what
happened was we lived in Redondo and you
had the alarm clock on your side of it
and I never had one online because I
didn't have an outlet near my nightstand
and so I reasoned my reasoning was well
there's no outlet I guess I can't have a
clock on my nightstand right rather than
getting a battery-powered one maybe
oh so stupid so for years I didn't have
one on my side because I couldn't figure
out how and then we moved twice since
redondo and then don't forget that in
the last place we also had one charger
for a phone on one side one chair we had
a breakthrough moment where he said you
know what we could plug an extension
cord and then there could be a plug for
you on the other side and we're like wow
it's a really big moment all right the
extension cord idea was
you know there's no outlet there but we
could just put a power source there
through an extension cord it was a big
big breakthrough it yes months and
months is together and then that was a
thing we were like oh yeah just because
that thing's not there doesn't mean you
can't figure out a way to make it work
this time I am constantly asking you
what time it is
you see me leaning over to see the clock
I caught you at 4:00 in the morning you
went to take a piss
and then you walked over to my side of
it and leaned over me to look at my
clock and that's when it occurred to me
this I woke up that morning and I go
poor Tommy is walking to my side of it I
go ah I know I'll buy him his own alarm
clock own clock and guess what I got it
I can now tell the time on my side the
fuck is wrong with wife's ticket and you
do without a side clock for how long I
mean we're coming up on I mean in this
home what it's November I have six seven
months or so and in the last place
another about close to a year going on
two years where I don't get to see the
time at night when you want to know is
in midnight is it 3:00 yeah right and
then before that I that way in Redondo
I'm every night what time is it
I wear watch but I in the day at night
yeah but then I remember in Redondo
Beach going why don't we put over clock
on the wall so I both see it yeah bed
and I'm like that that theory just and
like what is wrong with us that we both
that isn't courage like just for you
know a few bucks you can buy a fucking
we don't have the figure it out finally
we have deal with it you deal with what
you got
he doesn't work around there's a
workaround for that god damn it how does
it feel though like last night was your
first night being able to tell the time
whenever you want yeah that crazy it was
really cool like I knew what time I was
going to bed bed now and then you woke
up in the morning and I go
Tom what time is it Lugo's 6:20 yep I
know you so empowered hello and welcome
to how to create a perceptual map using
Excel my name is Jeff fellows the worse
through the road hate Excel as an
alternative I already knocked free ready
to by the way Excel templates to choose
there's nobody more arrogant than
someone that's mastered Excel they talk
about it like oh you don't know how to
make toast just fucking put the bread
and you press the button dude Excel is
so hard on a in a big hurry showed you
want ride you highlight in his control
l7 yet I like the column and then it's
the sum of all these things you can make
it in minutes and that's available at
sexual Maps calm yeah here the first
thing you need to having flashback need
a list of brand at least two attributes
seared the attributes scored like arm
and if you want to this is optional yeah
I'm included I'm not a chair well
definitely boring but you think they
would have created a program more
intuitive than Excel because Excel is so
counterintuitive it you could take a
fucking class to learn how to do it so
how is that a useful program it's so
hard
yes it's very hard god I almost fuckin
flaunt that class every time I mean when
did they start teaching us do you
remember that when they started teaching
us excel things I was in college
oh and I had to learn it from my
statistics class and my friend Bronwyn
was good at it so I paid her in beer to
do my homework because I could not
figure out Excel by the way did you see
this that steven seagal yeah as in band
of course people have been sending this
to me nonny tail stop now
the last time i asked the CIA to provide
me with people and answers they gave me
people and answers that answered my
questions the way they wanted it to be
answered me the ukraine has banned
Steven Seagal as a national security
threat making him the latest of several
cultural figures to be blacklisted ah
the ukrainian security service said it
had forbidden Seagal entry to the
country for five years Wow and a letter
published by the new site ' the services
press secretary later confirmed the ban
to other media a letter said such as
Isis made when a person has committed
socially dangerous actions that
contradict the interests of maintaining
Ukraine's security the move comes after
the actor received citizenship in Russia
which has backed separatists in a
simmering conflict in eastern Ukraine
President Putin handed Seagal a Russian
passport and told him he hopes their
personal relationship will remain and
continue during a meeting in the Kremlin
last year so there you have it mr.
Steven Seagal is no longer welcome in
the Ukraine that's a pretty big deal and
I only the king of in promise for
forgive my fangs
I do forgive you good for the Ukraine
yeah good thinking why why does he need
Russian citizenship I mean well he's a
Russian ethnic or is he yeah
I had no idea well then that is yeah but
it's also because I think it's a big
part the big part of it is that in
certain parts of the world he still
feels like it's 1992 yes baby yeah I
know Eastern Europe they felt like old
show like oh fuck when you kick a lot of
people laughing yeah still get excited
by him unless who's women speaking of
God out there oh my god yeah
listen let's go man that's a woman doing
a karate exit and shit
feeling that shit
tsubame thought to do that
she's great that is the date I hope she
want served it for that level why
screaming like that it's unnecessary but
it doesn't look weird
they know it's my dream like that and
usually that you know the funny thing is
her screams don't align with the point
of a hex yeah yeah obvious ads ponch as
you can as you move yeah he's like
screaming
right before she moves yeah very
peculiar yeah the timings off yeah
pretty crazy but this is not even
screaming during the kick go there all
right Sarah okay guys bring it in Sarah
yeah this really looked like an bullshit
what you doing mostly moved look really
nice a fairly basic
there are Sarah
all right Sarah you know like that
doesn't look like that could kick
anybody's ass what she said not you know
I don't know I agree fucking dance me I
remember when I took kung-fu and then
they teach you like the the Dragons
whatever movements you know it's really
just a a dance move you don't really
excited people like that they just
showed I saw a video of a like a
traditionally trained MMA guy yeah
against some kung fu master oh you don't
want to see it really oh my god the the
MMA guy just pummeled him yeah and it
was like really bad it wasn't ma'am it
wasn't cool not funny like your mother
guy was like you know trying to deflect
some of it and the guy just beat him
like they had to pull him off and
they're like this guy's got to die if
you don't stop doing this Jackie
he was a kung fu master you know yeah
yeah and there's no match for MMA which
is well I'm saying that well that's but
the guy obviously got involved because
he's like this makes sense let's see how
these rules of a fight you know do
against each other it was banana yeah I
mean the guy disagree he punched through
the guys ridiculous deflections yeah
just fucking be him be some yeah
beat him on the ground and kept
pummeling him it's like um okay I think
we know which is the better all right
thank you
you know you fart through your asshole
you know I mean yeah that's the whole
point of thing yeah dad boner Oh fishing
that could happen to that the wooden is
classic got ten pounds I just made all
my I just made up my deferens that's a
10-pounder top thank you at the window
that's how I just made up the difference
okay mark no mark Donna seconds for you
[Music]
okay okay yeah that's a dead bar yeah
but again I feel like you know it makes
sense why he's excited yeah she was
obviously behind like he was making in
other words he probably caught something
earlier it wasn't as big
he won whatever competition he's in yeah
so you know I celebrate his dad bone
around yeah any - I like those sporty
glasses those are always a real dad
fashion gift and sexy right definitely
the multicolored shiny in the Rope
Oakley only with the rope yeah you got
to have the rope however you got to have
the rope that's what that's why you wear
them you know because you're fishing
yeah because they could fall off that's
right that's what I'm saying I like the
dads who wear it just like walking
around the airport that's what I'm
saying it's off as long as it isn't what
dad doesn't want to lose it but on the
boat it makes the most sense yeah but
it's cooler when you carry it off the
bows certainly I also like the dads who
put the glasses in front of like on
their chest which is where I'm backward
you let them hang not re you let them
hang backwards on your back so back
shirt yeah yeah like you they tuck them
into the back give me that yeah that's
how I was even thinking or if you want
to go to the guy fieri
that's when I put them on the back of
your head that's why the sunglasses
facing progress guy kind of patented
that move hmm yeah really sexy look yeah
[Music]
the real dad reaction right there
seriously let's see here
seriously seriously oh I see Guy Fieri
yeah douche bag sunglasses it's kind of
wet like I I don't have anything against
guy theory personally of course but as
an aesthetic it's a really douche bag
sort of ascetic right yeah isn't it
those so see how ya puts them on that's
crazy
the back yeah it's like he's like the
poster boy for a douche bag just
aesthetically I mean again I don't know
him as a person
yeah but the whole vibe is like I'm a
fucking I know like it's weird right
that he embraces the douchebag look I
think you know that's just who he is
right and and also here's the weird
thing when you want to talk about this
this whole thing has really worked for
him ya know he's really successful in
every way I'm not shitting on the guy
but as the look the look is like I think
I don't know if it's true or not but I
heard please tell me this is true he has
a car collection where they're all like
the same color are they all fire like
fire print I'm sure you like flames are
all yellow
yeah bright yes like the real
attention-seeking color yeah needs a lot
of attention yeah so here you see like
an old Corvette more recent Corvette
there's a flames like I said yes flames
paint flames on everything Wrangler
looks like there's a Camaro back there a
big pickup what is this here some dodge
maybe yeah by Rosa look at it into our
collection I can't believe he makes that
much money on that show what's amazing
isn't it yeah well good for him I mean
it's great that's great but and what it
it's totally him to have them all in
yellow yeah it's a douche bag or all
yolk that I'm really weird man really
bizarre that he would have that many
fucking yellow cars you think that like
one yellow would kind of be part it
would be your collection right you'd be
like I got one yellow yeah like you
wanna I mean I you think you'd want to
vary it just to be like I've got a red
Corvette I've got the yellow Hummer I've
got whatever you know we should tell him
how to collect his cars we should tell
him it's up to us I want you to start
reaching out to guide you please play
the fly Oh tenant oh yeah yeah yeah so
you sent me this audio file this is a
well why don't you set it up I was
flying back home from Park Nix and I
noticed that the woman doing the rules
FDA whatever
as right FDA that's a Food Drug
Administration yeah okay reading the
rules safety stuff
she was really mushy mouth and marbled
and she wasn't pronouncing the words
they all jumbled together so I recorded
her and at first like really weird
sounds normal yes then as you start
listening you're like oh yeah like she's
having my first o or something um of
their mouth use the mouth can't remember
advisory that level minoxidil honor
needed
abba-baba-baba hopefuls oxygen and the
lavatory's are held in a plastic
retainer clip to use the Mount Apo the
mounts out of a plastic retainer clip
and rig normally super long yeah unless
we address some a water line in years
hero nutritionist be careful it is one
of the flotation - to use at float up a
ticket right here she's looks at when I
see an error calculation arms to the
shop like a charity I'll tell you what's
going on here
this is Nigeria yeah this bitch is sick
reading that yes and she also knows by
law she has to read it yeah so her
feeling is let me just get through this
thing as fast as often because she's not
a smoke she's what she is doing is she's
reading it really fast
yeah she's not stopping her sentences in
now comas are over it she's just like
vitae driver and so she's running
through it all the world like multi cuz
a lot you know what happens is like if
she doesn't even pronounce some
syllables she still gets through it
faster oh yeah we're sitting is like
finish reading a fucking thing
and that lines maps are located the
former cabin in the event of a water
line your fight isn't over in the adult
you know poverty received information
card is all new paralytics emergency
exits are for this aircraft that may
know through it you entered our service
directly across from us for additional
emergency exits are located over the
links with cabin to any side exercise
all right identify these X's 1 blah blah
blah Gentile energy escape mouth finding
if there were to evacuate follow those
lights to the nearest exit keeping them
on an exit may be located by fog by the
way we're also forgetting a message you
definitely have some Vogel from yeah
yeah yeah Megan and I have been together
for nearly three years I will get
interval that experience with the
blockers and instructions provided by
your crew regulations for you from
tampering with disabling or destroying
the source enter starter lavatories
notable urban america blog because what
happens is some of them understand i
think some of them it's their time to
shine other words right warmers
yes and they say exits are located in
above the wings right rear in the front
of the aircraft take a moment now to
look around and locate the nearest exit
and they they read it like they're
they're reading farthest south west we
used to do the jokes like in the event
crash landing of course there won't be
one like that that dumb shit I fucking
hate the joke reading I do do I don't
need to be entertained but I do need you
to enunciate a little bit I mean that
was jive had some marbled mess next to
me going yeah I know
they went really really and Southwest
used to really ham it up I guess they
stopped doing that yeah a lot funny now
they still do it they laugh and then
remember they throw the peanuts down the
aisle on the plane on an incline turn
out and I'm gonna go turn off your
cellphone's your blackberries your
blueberries strawberries that's a sin
people like that yeah really yeah really
laughing it up right that blueberry joke
that left with the black dad whenever
you're a comedian and you have
moments of self-doubt you like em am i
funny am i is it work that I'm doing go
on one of those Southwest flight watch
people laughed I so stupid fucking
instructions at the flight attendants
right now and then you walk away like
I'm on the funniest fucking people girl
yeah right I will give you all the
confidence you need right to have
somebody do fucking seatbelt joke about
make sure if you don't know I can come
over and I'll click it on for you just
pull like this yes don't click it over
your head over your waist you hear
people like that on the plane you wanna
you know what yeah I'm gonna find geniu
I'm funnier than I'm Richard Pryor
compared to this dummy I got to
interrupt real quick a call just came in
don't know what it says but I feel like
it's worth I think you're lying
no I'm serious I don't know what this is
I think I know what it is hey Tom it ha
it burnt again that words it's some kind
of eating me up inside of your that
message but I you know I've been
thinking about it and honestly I don't I
haven't known you as long as Christina
so Sharon um I haven't known her you as
long as her solo like I've been thinking
about it and I Club Nami for a couple
years and you've been very charming and
hopefully new year I think I love you
Tom and you know I'm there's nobody in
the world that's better suited for each
other than you and Christina and you
know I'm not knocking your personality
but I was like wait a second it's like
the law of averages you know unknown her
for a million years
and she's been consistently amazing and
awesome yeah and she's been such a good
friend to me I can't call you up on the
phone and tell you that you got better
personality because Christina's she's
like she's so quick and she's so
generous and she's so bright and silly
and was a buyer's fun and sometimes she
says something like I wish my brain was
like that yeah so I'm calling because
why
my painting this position honestly
because I feel like you know I like very
difficult it's been very emotional and
left a message and my first thought was
like shit I should have just kept my
mouth shut and then so okay so I'm
calling because I want to change how
unchanged how about you you yes Tina has
the better personality and that's that I
knew it I don't know actually do it no I
think I think you have I personally I
don't know this is so difficult
I don't know it's it's Christina ah no
it's you I don't know no my um burned
your very first on huh oh yes that's
great she did have some doubt though
that's got to feel good
cuz she felt a little bit of doubt what
are you paying my friend not paying
anything don't even know Mary Lynn
especially Mary Lynn she heard about it
when I saw at the store she goes oh I
heard about the personality sandwich if
she was your hands down she did not she
did I'm gonna have to do my research
she's 100% said that whatever's I'm
gonna have to call these friends yep
that top dog laughs I love so much his
blonde joke gloves yep
does that bum you out that your dad
thinks that stuff so funny and you're
like you're like the best working comic
out there and he's like I love those
blonde yoga buddy
meanwhile his own son is like the best
but I worse you are - but he of course
guy I had this conversation with people
I mean we've talked about it I talked to
his people of time about how I met with
this great writer last week and he was
telling me how he wrote I don't like
divulge all these things but basically
he wrote an amazing episode of
television
hmm that is really highly you know
celebrated and it's really smart and
really funny
and his dad was like I think
what you're doing and his dad's his
dad's a successful smart guy but yeah
but then his dad told him about the
Borat scene where he brings the poop
down the stairs he goes now that's funny
right he's like you don't think that
this like emmy-nominated thing I wrote
now is like no but see that's why you're
in comedy
yes now if your parents approved of you
you'd have there would be nothing
compelling you to tell jokes to
strangers and get that Wordle you got to
get it somewhere you gotta get it ain't
from your folks I know
I know man it's crazy no could you
imagine who you would be if your mom and
dad approved of you you we surely
wouldn't have this show no why would you
do it there'd be no reason yeah to
cultivate a personality to go out there
for 15 years grind one guy a week in the
clubs I know a many my dad laughs yeah
so I can shape something and I'm not
talking about a blonde joke I'm saying
within my wheelhouse I know what kind of
thing would make him laugh but every
once in a while I'll lob out a I
genuinely think this is funny
let me see if you do think it's funny I
thought never know silence total silence
yeah and then like but do you think this
one I don't never mind I'll like I'll
read them I'll say I said this about
this yeah no because oh yeah so I was
talking to your mother and he'll just
I'm like wow I get bombs so hard still
it just doesn't it's not it's never
going to be the thing never going to be
well you know what thank God for it
otherwise we wouldn't have the life we
have today sure of course
thank God our teen I got improved I got
a big thing this weekend I'm going back
to Oregon he had a bad bike got a bad
fight this weekend I'm going back to
Oregon or again I think Oregon Oregon
Oregon Oregon that's a good one
and I'm doing two shows in blue-jean
otherwise known as Eugene goat go ducks
Oregon and then
or Qin I'm back there Glenn I believe
that early shows I know the early show
in Portland is sold out at revolution
Hall there's still tickets left to the
Late Show which i think is at 10:30
revolution Hall Saturday night Eugene
Oregon I'm there Friday night and there
are still tickets left of The Late Show
I'm there with Ryan sickle-cell Sickler
so if you want to come see us we're
going to both be there all that showings
additionally I'm coming to Tucson
Arizona
I bet toxin then Reno Nevada Reno is
what we mean
Chiho Hall and then in ridiculous
Pechanga casino C macula and then I go
I'm in the deep dirty I'm in Richmond
Virginia Beach Virginia Gene's burrow
North Carolina Asheville North Carolina
and Charles come good South Carolina has
really got online and then I also have
oh I'm coming to Montreal Canadiens Aman
tree all right before I go to Wilmington
Delaware and I also go to Hampton Beach
and finally balls in whore's Maryland
Baltimore the city that reads then off
to my Australia and of course a live
podcast with my Blue Gene on August 20
what gene I don't know
August 23rd in addition to that we have
added two more live podcasts in Irvine
on separate month firm vine firm bond at
separate months here's why tough to make
it go all the time so we just added them
a few months apart we're doing one
July 9th that's on sale now and another
one we're doing it a click on this here
October October 8th which is obviously a
long way away but we've we've added them
already so July 9th and October 8th
there 7 p.m. shows at the Irvine improv
we're going to do a live podcast I'm
hiring sound engineers to come because
yeah you know and that's another one
that we're like why don't we have a
clock next to our bed we should be
higher I don't that was a what we
learned our lesson we're doing though
those will be those sound a lot
different than the last time but also
there'll be a lot of fun to come to the
live show Jean glue Jean Jean I am may
19th and 20th and Jude or kiddies at
Gotham come on your clubs June 1st
through 3rd Denver Mambo dong fur dog
fur at the calm of calm works Comedy
Works downtown Jesus June 16th and 17th
man friend disco at the punch Rhine
Kennedy crab come see me tickets at
thousand ranch calm spelled out thank
you for everybody who has already come
see me it's been really really fun you
guys are very encouraging said it I said
I'm in those live dates you said you
don't say you feel me on time now
oh yeah exactly you mean go mm ranch
calm and buy some ticket to see those
big mushy purples I love how he says
mushy purple purple same I need to pee
huh again mushing purple honey this has
been in my thing here for a while it
says a weird Mme interview I'm not sure
what's going on I don't know the details
but we can watch whatever this is see
visiting the president's and TV and
we're here at dragon house and I'm here
with Oh Matt major okay Matt looks maybe
like you should be 5150 or something
right and I'm opponent non-binary I
prefer not to know anything about my
opponent okay I guess that's a what
motivates you in the butt
okay let me tell you what motivates me
you know what motivates me is staying in
the dark tunnel I stay in the dark
tunnel
cuz when you're in the darkness you
can't see shit anyway
so what fucking difference does it make
to know who this man is right I get it
is that I shadow it is that's why I was
thinking it might be as in Jersey
situation so um matter if I don't know
what your opponent's gonna expect from
you I don't know what expect from you
but what school do you fight for Matt
fine the dark tunnel Hey the dark tunnel
man that's kind of scary yeah that's
right that's a good analysis yeah what
the same as those kinds of stuff in the
dark tunnel you know what do you do you
know what the beavers in the holes are
links to this guy with the quarters of
committing a horrific crime it would not
be that surprising right yep yeah yep
of yours link and you're in the tunnel
in the hole and a big fat beaver came in
there with two books sharp teeth she
were there with the flu here Yeah right
you think you're gonna make it out of
here I don't think so man I'm the beaver
in a hole oh dear yeah it's a chemical
imbalance see how much funnier though
Kevin weeks is talking about taking a
nap yeah different yeah cuz this is not
see he's not aware of his world right
yes they grounded for it to be funny
true you need have one foot in the door
of reality so how do you see the flight
ending it's not that I see an ending
don't ever want it to him oh no one just
work to begin this guy's smiling yeah I
mean like fucking terrified yeah I don't
know nothing about this guy either right
now so it's kind of a scary thing so uh
yeah variation my prediction oh dear
Christ don't ask any more questions the
rapture oh Christ
okay that's why I predicted I predict
that the vampire aliens you get in the
middle of this whole thing they're going
to be like we don't want the
our use ion okay well I never you know I
am the reason for it all I'm the reason
why silver satis ass down he doesn't
want to bring in hell either acting
humble your ass motherfucker now but any
last word thank you so much thank you me
this opportunity
that's a lay a lot of people don't want
to give me an opportunity man a lot of
people so fucking free heart I'm a bit
scared myself man yeah
yes Matt major Bellator fighter
reputation one of the strangest men see
can't tell if it's a performance or if
he's gently de strange I want to see if
since the time this has happened if
anything with this guy I don't know
anything about him Matt see major in a
real seems real I don't know I shadow is
a nice touch too yeah maybe his acting
is like I'm the crazy like I should be
playing a role you know possibly
interesting choice what does say this
interview with homeless MMA fighter is
wrong we're okay there you go oh look at
a minute say no more that major not as
have you been reading the posts on our
next door app about the homeless guy and
is undercarriage yeah by the bank the
white people around here real freaked
out by him
yeah and it's by the way that next door
thing someone got me onto that it's
super fucking just racially motivated
people are just like there's a black guy
okay I think I am kind of depressing
when you start like if you what they do
is they build up and then you can see
them and they're always like sub
brownish guy okay
either that or it's really benign like
raccoons are eating trash in my yard
anybody's help with the wreck anybody
having trouble with the wind right it's
always when she hears a siren but then
there was that really funny one that you
shared yeah black guy a black guy wrote
he's like I'm new in the neighborhood
I'm black if you see me walking around I
like to get fresh air from time to time
yeah no need to post yeah looks like
good one dude yeah cuz they'll be like
there was a guy sitting in his car and
not doing anything but he was black just
a heads up of the heads that up there is
the don't raisin bread you know though
they'll try to make it sound like
they're not being scared yeah but
they'll be like a african-american males
we're just driving and they're not even
doing anything they're just driving I
don't know if anybody seen them they're
in a white car and they're just driving
you know what's the story though yeah
did they drove yes yes silly silliness
there's nothing going on guys in the
neighborhood nothing not a fuckin thing
nothing to report all right all right
Jean we should run je8
and I know as it's singular right it is
do you want to hear I think where he did
Chinese eyes British oh yeah song that's
yesterday's news
got any coming those farts they would
like that one - you nasty by DJ huh no
no there's a bunch of songs but I don't
know which ones been played pushes theme
oh my god much the same with you yeah
push come on hear that yeah alright
thank you guys for listening don't
forget to go to your mom's house
podcast.com
thousand ranch - Oh check out the vlog
oh yeah yeah blue band posted a behind
the scenes he did a really good job
that's fantastic log of the last of
those Irvine shows we did a couple
months ago and it's really cool he did
it behind the scenes you get to see how
we get ready what we do before and after
shows Yoshii a special interview with
him it's really good it's on the you
tonight amaze on the YouTube stage all
right thanks guys see you next week
since I'm like them yeah me Wow
I meant the melody say wow I didn't
remember that from Catholic school real
nigga real nigga real got a real gospel
is a nigga crazy crazy crazy I'm doing a
job getting up getting said they don't
medium-plus is a big word crazy you know
if they've loved it - chatter yeah yeah
[Music]
clarity we'll look you're gonna get to
that right Wow dropping after that one
technician I didn't make it up not only
thing